let's now tackle a classic thought
experiment in probability called
the monty hall problem and it's called
the monty hall problem because monty
hall was the game show host and let's
make a deal where they would set up a
situation very similar to the monty hall
problem that we're about to say so let's
say that on the show you're presented
with three curtains so you're the
contestant this little chef looking
character right over there you're
presented with three curtains curtain
number one curtain number two and
curtain number three and you're told
that behind one of these three curtains
there's a fabulous prize something that
you really want a car or a vacation or
some type of large amount of cash and
then behind the other two and we don't
know which they are there is something
that you do not want a a new pet goat or
an ostrich or something like that or a
beach ball something that is not as good
as the cash prize and so your goal is to
try to find the cash prize and they say
guess which one or which one would you
like to select and so let's say that you
select door number one or curtain number
one
then the Monty Hall and let's make a
deal crew we'll make it a little bit
more interesting they won't just show
you whether or not you won they'll then
show you one of the other two doors or
one of the other two curtains and
they'll show you one of the other two
curtains that does not have the prize
and no matter which one you pick there
will always be at least one other
curtain that does not have the prize
there might be two if you picked right
but there will always be at least one
other curtain that does not have the
prize and then they will show it to you
and so let's say that they show you
curtain number three and so curtain
number three has the goat and then they
will ask you do you want to switch do
you want to switch to curtain number two
and the question here is does it make a
difference are you better off holding
fast sticking to your guns staying with
the original guess are you better off
switching to whatever curtain is left or
does it not matter it's just random
probability and it's not going to make a
difference whether you switch or not
so that is the brainteaser start pause
the video now I encourage you to think
about it in the next video we will start
to analyze the solution a little bit
deeper what whether it makes any
difference at all
so now I've assumed that you've unpause
it you've thought deeply about it
perhaps you have an opinion on it now
let's work it through a little bit and
at any point I encourage you to pause it
and kind of extrapolate beyond what what
I've already talked about so let's think
about the game show from the show's
point of view so the show knows where
there's the goat and where there isn't
the goat so let's door number one door
number two and door number three so
let's say that our let's say that our
prize is right over here
so our prize is the car our prize is the
car and that we have a goat over here
goat over here and over here we also
have maybe we have two goats in this
situation so what are we going to do is
the gameshow remember the contestants
don't know this we know this so the
contestant picks door number one right
over here then we can't lift door number
two because there's a car back there
we're going to lift door number three
and we're going to expose we're going to
expose this goat in which case it
probably would be good for the for the
person to switch if the person picks if
the person picks door number two then we
as the gameshow can show either door
number one or door number three and then
it actually does not make sense for the
person to switch if they picked door
number three then we have to show door
number one because we can't pick door
number two and in that case it is it
actually makes a lot of sense for the
person to switch now with that out of
the way let's think about the
probabilities given the two strategies
so if you don't switch so let's if you
don't switch don't switch or another way
to think about this strategy is you
always stick to your guns you always
stick to your first guess well in that
situation what is your probability what
is your probability of winning well
there's three doors the the prize is
equally likely to behind any one of them
so there's three possibilities one has
the outcome that you desire the
probability of winning will be one-third
if you don't switch likewise your
probability of losing your probability
of losing well there's two ways that you
can lose out of three possibilities it's
going to be two-thirds and these are the
only possibilities and these add up to
one
right over here so don't switch one
third chance of winning now let's think
about the switching situation so let's
say always when you always switch let's
think let's think about how this might
play out what is your probability of
winning
what is your probability of winning and
before we even think about that think
about how you would win if you always
switch so if you pick wrong the first
time if you pick wrong the first time
they're going to show you this and so
you should always switch so if you pick
door number one they're going to show
you door number three you should switch
if you picked wrong door number three
they're going to show you door number
one you should switch so if you if you
picked wrong and switch you will always
win let me write this down and this
insight actually came from one of the
middle school students in the summer
camp that Khan Academy was running it's
actually a fabulous way to think about
this so if you pick wrong so if it's
step one so initial pick is wrong
initial pick is wrong so you pick one of
the two wrong doors and then in step two
you always switch you always you always
switch you will land on the car because
if you picked one of the wrong doors
they're going to have to show the other
wrong door and so if you switch you're
going to end up on the right answer so
what is the probability of winning if
you always switch well it's going to be
the probability that you initially
picked wrong well what's the probability
that you initially picked wrong well
there's two out of the three ways to
initially pick wrong so you actually
have a two-thirds chance of winning
there's a two-thirds chance you're going
to pick wrong and then switch into the
right one
likewise what's your probability of
losing what's your probability of losing
given that you're always going to switch
well the way that you would lose is you
pick right you pick right you pick
correctly and step two they're going to
show an empty they're going to show one
of the two empty or non prize doors and
then step three you're going to switch
into the other empty you are going to
switch into the other the other empty
door but either way you're definitely
going to switch so the only way to lose
if you're always going to switch is to
pick right the first time well what's
the probability of you picking right the
first time well that is only 1/3 so you
see it here and it sometimes
counterintuitive but hopefully this
makes sense as to why it isn't you have
a one-third chance of winning if you
stick to your guns and a two-thirds
chance of winning if you always switch
another way to think about it is when
you first make your initial pick there's
a one-third chance that it's there
there's a one-third chance there and
there's a 2/3 chance there's a
two-thirds chance that it's in one of
the other two doors and they're going to
empty out one of them so when you switch
you essentially are capturing that 2/3
probability and we see that right there
so hopefully you enjoyed that